the endless sort of hysteria that
hillary just showed right there it's
just coming from almost every democrat
at this point i would love to find a
democrat who wasn't doing it and i would
gladly have them on the show and treat
them the same way i treat you guys and
all my other guests
gq ran a crazy fluff piece cover piece
with aoc this week and there's some real
gems in there just to talk about how
they're ramping up the insanity i got
some quotes here from you from aoc uh
this is the gq piece on aoc over the
course of our conversations the
congresswoman typically answered in a
confident fast-paced patter each
sentence closely chasing the tale of the
last but now her speech slowed to a
crawl and for the first time in the
hours we had spent speaking she broke
eye contact burying her gaze in the arm
of her chair
tears pooled in the corners of her eyes
jesus christ i'm going to barf that was
me
i hold two contradictory things in mind
at the same time one is just the
relentless belief that anything is
possible she said but at the same time
my experience here has given me a front
row seat to how deeply and unconsciously
as well as consciously so many people in
this country hate women and they hate
women of color people ask me questions
about the future and realistically i
can't even tell you if i'm going to be
alive in september and that weighs very
heavily on me and it's not just the
right wing misogyny transcends political
ideology left right or center this grip
of patriarchy affects us all not just
women men as i mentioned before but also
ideologically there's an extraordinary
lack of self-awareness in so many places
and so those are two very conflicting
things i admit to sometimes believing
that i live in a country that would
never let that happen i'm a little
confused here because i've done many
public events with you and as far as i
know i don't care about such things but
you are a woman and a woman of color i
have seen all sorts of people give you
standing ovations and sign autographs
and take selfies these are supposed to
be scary racist white supremacists is
aoc a little confused or maybe drunk
what's going on here you know there's a
lot to unpack there she said she didn't
know if she was gonna make it until
september if that's the timeline that
we've got right now i need to get going
on that bucket list um but i it seems
like she's having a really really hard
time and i don't know whether or not
this is theatrical because we know she's
gone to the border fence and cried she
thought she was going to die on january
6 but i would like to take a comment
like that i don't think i will make it
until september or i don't know if i'll
make it to september very seriously but
what does she think is going to happen
is it climate that's going to kill her
is it the mag of republicans who are
coming after her or is it her own mental
health and if it is that we should be
taking it seriously it's just really
hard with all the theatrics that she has
constantly engaged in to take a comment
like that seriously robert really
stunning and brave of you amla to just
sit there while dave assumed your gender
i should cancel him you are yeah
i didn't say it you did you know
robert robert is it i mean look i know
irony is dead and all of that stuff but
you know when she says you know she's
the victim in all this i mean what lays
beneath everything she said there is
that she is a victim for whatever reason
she's a victim at the same time she's
calling everyone else these horrible
things does she not realize that could
cause a situation where perhaps they
won't make it to september because of
her inflammatory language is that
totally lost on her
well i think both aoc and hillary
statements reflect confession through
projection which is one of my favorite
uh
sayings
because it's people who if you get
randomly accused of something that makes
no sense by somebody just assume that
they're confessing themselves and
they're describing their own behavior
and that's what like aoc saying man
there's a lot of lack of self-awareness
in the world that precisely summarizes
aoc utter lack of self-awareness
completely there's politics of
narcissism this sort of instagram-driven
politics of people that completely lack
self-awareness it's their defining
aspect and then the same with hillary
this is someone who tried to create
fascistic aspects in our own government
with her ties to various operations and
inside and outside government the
clinton foundation being the most
notoriously corruption of our government
in recent modern history uh until the
biden family took over the white house
and and yet here she's talking about
someone who weaponized the fbi who was
bragging selling merchandise over the
fact that she destroyed a bunch of
emails that were actually work
classified while the president gets
rated for things that he had a legal
right to declassify so it shows the
degree of absurdity that is occurring uh
but
both are cases of confession through
projection
spencer when uh when they treat her like
the queen
and then they treat sort of republican
women horribly mira flores who's the new
congresswoman from texas is a great
example this woman wins a seat in a
border town in texas you know a month
and a half ago or so uh first time the
republicans had the seat in over a
hundred years the new york times writes
an article and i quote the rise of the
far right latina uh but again it's the
double standard thing that we we just
need to move past it right i mean do we
need to keep calling it out or should we
just let it go and figure out a better
way to fight back
i mean i i'm sorry spencer i just think
it's important with the with the comment
that hillary made to to point out what
authoritarianism looks like and it looks
like big government expansion of
regulations mass censorship and staffing
off political dissidence and that's
exactly what they're engaged in
yeah
spencer
i certainly think we can get over the
you know democrats or the real racists
pulling out our hair running around on
fire like this is who they are they've
told us who they are a million times
we've seen it over and over and over
again we know they're going to behave
this way and we do need to develop some
strategies not just for complaining
about it but actually pushing back
against it electing people that will
kick these guys out of office and so on
and and so forth it all does however
raise the really important question
which is when can we
expect the aoc guest spot on meghan
markle's new podcast this is i think
the country demands to know we need this
appearance and they do deserve each
other i mean britain is mourning the
death of its monarch as we speak and you
know she leaves behind her a royal
family that is in some ways in shambles
precisely because of this this trend
that's going on on both sides of the
atlantic people governing uh not only by
emotion and victimization but also
narcissism and and self-glamorization
that's you know again all aoc has to
offer she's very good at it she looks
great in that gq shoot you have to hand
it to her um but i think the the thing
that we've got to get better at is just
acknowledging that these these people
are you know pandering fascistic bigots
and we gotta you know move past that and
uh and fight our own battles